president trump is using attacks on the
female congresswoman known as the squad
to fire up his supporters
he called out the former lawmakers of
color by name at a campaign rally last
night in north carolina
that drew raucous applause from the
crowd and a chant
based on the president's racist tweet
tonight i have a suggestion for the
hate-filled extremists
who are constantly trying to tear our
country down they never have anything
good to say
that's why i say hey if they don't like
it let them leave let them leave
omar has a history of launching
vicious anti-semitic
[Applause]
screens
you can hear it there the crowd chanting
send her back
we're talking about congresswoman ilhan
omar she was born in somalia
but she is an american citizen she has
lived here since she was a young
teenager
omar responded on twitter with a picture
of her in congress and wrote this
i am where i belong at the people's
house and you're just gonna have to deal
with it
major garrett joins us from washington
major you have seen plenty of these
trump rallies did the scene last night
surprise you
well gail with you and tony and anthony
yesterday alma said in new york what did
i say
i said the president is looking for
replacement for hillary clinton
now i didn't know when i said that hours
later there would be a chant coming from
a trump rally reminiscent of the 2016
hillary clinton chat lock her up which
was
send her back but this is consistent
with this sense among some trump
supporters and it's worth pointing out
that you can see in the video not every
trump supporter is chanting that
but some do believe that there is a
dividing line in america and that the
president is on the love america
patriotic side
and those who vehemently disagree with
him are not
now i've been to nearly 80 trump rallies
i talked to trump supporters at every
single one of them i spent more than an
hour and a half with them
at the orlando reelection rally
individually they present as
patriotic earnest they love the
president love the country
believe these chants are somewhat
ingested and are kind of surprised
people get
fearful about them that is a dividing
line in perception
and the way politics plays out and trump
supporters don't think they're doing
anything wrong
even when they chant like this they
believe the critics of the president are
too sensitive
and they're the ones who are unhinged it
is the biggest most visible dividing
line
in american politics major you know when
you're when you're watching it i think
for a lot of people this is very
frightening i
i just want to help i want i would like
you to help us understand
why you can't disagree with the
president without being called an
american
i just met the squad the other day i
don't know them i had never
talked to any of them before that
interview and only spent 30 minutes not
one of them has ever said
i hate america not one of them has ever
said i don't want to be here in fact
i would say they love this country so
much they spoke with such pride about
being in the being in congress they
pointed out where they sat in that room
and the bills that they passed and the
passion that they have for this country
and their people and their constituents
so
for him to say with a with a big
microphone they hate this country that
just is simply
not true and it scares me that he's
putting that narrative out there
he's putting that narrative out there
and for the republican party which gail
has become the trump party
when the president says you disagree
with me he is essentially saying
you are doing something un-american he
regards his supporters
as patriots true american patriots
oftentimes
election emails sent to trump supporters
will say
true american patriots this is one of
the things that's at stake in 2020
what is our definition nationally
collectively of what patriotism is
or isn't is dissent unpatriotic is that
the essential core
of the trump message some trump
supporters actually believe that
others are not exactly sure that but it
is one of the central i would argue
primal questions in american politics in
the 2020 election
what is our definition of our self what
are we comfortable with
what are we willing to live with yeah
indeed who are we
yeah who are we that is we do what do we
do all right major thank you very much
we appreciate the insights this
conversation will definitely continue
but we'll leave it here for now